welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania that's right as we Embark upon
Marvel phase five in the Multiverse Saga
the big question is do you guys just put
the word Quantum in front of everything
yes we do so let us wave goodbye to the
yellow brick road of the sometimes
stinky phase four and figure out if
Kang's ring city is connected to the 10
Rings that's right we're going crazy
here let's break it down frame by frame
and let us begin over Sunny San
Francisco my current city no place like
home let me tell you we're Elton John's
Goodbye Yellow Brick Road in which Elton
John and his lyricist Bernie toppin
wrote as a semi-autobiographical longing
for Melton to retire back to his
hometown before he concludes at the end
of the song that his future lies beyond
the yellow brick road because sorry
Dorothy you really can't go home again
such is the case for Scott in this movie
he may feel tempted to return to his
home before the time he lost during the
blip but his future truly lies ahead but
really I don't think this song is even
about Scott the way the Thor love and
thunder trailer used Sweet Child of Mine
as a secret mess message from Gore the
god Butcher and his daughter I think
this song is really coming from the
point of view of this movie's villain
King the Conqueror but is he really
gonna be the villain because remember
Thanos an Infinity War he was not really
the villain of that movie he was really
the protagonist of it and I think in
this movie Marvel's next big bad Kang
the Conqueror will be the surprise
protagonist this is going to be an
origin story for Kang and how this came
to conqueror is someone way worse than
the variant we met as he who remains in
Loki Kang wants something something was
taken from him and it is buried in his
past but while Thanos retired to a home
Farm Kang's future is beyond the yellow
brick road Beyond his current surrealist
Quantum Oz Kang will say goodbye to the
yellow brick road while the rest of us
will be stuck in it if you think about
it the Wizard of Oz has truly been a
recurring influence in recent Marvel
titles One Division had a good witch
versus a wicked witch a wicked witch who
rides a bike and snatches Toto's and Sam
raimi's Oz the Great and Powerful
reference on the movie theater Marquis
Loki introduced the Kang variant he who
remains hidden behind a literal Emerald
City of the Void he was a man behind the
current who uses smoke and mirrors
Remy's Multiverse of Madness cast
America Chavez is a Dorothy figure
running down a brick road all to fight a
wicked witch Wanda with no help from the
oz-like Illuminati and then most
recently werewolf by Knight ended with
its heroine attaining her Ruby
inheritance as her world shifts to
Technicolor set to Somewhere Over the
Rainbow so this isn't just like Film
School comparative analysis here folks
Marvel Studios is making it clear their
Wizard of Oz is Kang the Conqueror Scott
returns to his old job from the 2015
film at Baskin Robbins Baskin Robbins
always finds out to receive the award of
Employee of the century with his boss
Dale returning Scott's name tag of Jack
is still on his uniform and in this
photo this is the Alias Scott used to
avoid his criminal record coming up but
the real Easter egg here is that Paul
Rudd picked the name Jack as a shout out
to his son who's named Jack we love this
content because it's exciting and
interesting not like boring old water we
know we should be drinking water but
sometimes it's complete lack of flavor
makes us turn to less healthy liquid
options that doesn't have to be the case
because air up is a new way to enjoy
water and flavor without adding a bunch
of sugar your nose knows an air up knows
you knows let's unbox this baby Eric was
nice enough to send me one so let's take
a look
bam here it comes
so you see this this is a flavor ring
you just choose what you want your water
to taste like I want it to taste like
lime so I filled this bottle with
ordinary water I'm gonna press on the
flavor ring flavor ring is on and
activated so now I'm gonna take a sip
whoa it tastes like
whoa this is really cool so air up is
able to do this without adding anything
to the water itself because the people
who make it know how something tastes is
deeply connected to how it smells so air
Up's flavor ring uses your sense of
smell instead of sugar or weird chemical
additives in order to make the
healthiest thing you can drink the
tastiest thing you can drink too I gotta
try this again
it's like a magic trick to try air up
yourself just click the link in the
description below
it's crazy I'm definitely gonna get more
of this lime as soon as I'm done with
this video Scott's suit has been
upgraded so that the Pim bile is now
installed on his chest rather than in
his gloves maybe to avoid that
accidental button pushing I mean that
was never really practical this way it
might be more of a neural link where you
can just kind of think into a suit I
mean his brain waves are connected to
the ants can his brain waves be
connected to a suit a cave with an
Ant-Man backpack high five Scott and
Scott and hope attend a red carpet event
the banner reading humanitarian global
Service Awards from the anthropology
Society of the USA we know from d23
footage that Scott has a book and an
audiobook called look out for the little
guy and we know Kamala Khan listen to
Scott's podcast figure a little me so
that she in pretty much all Society
could learn what happened in endgame so
really Scott is probably the biggest
celebrity Among The Avengers right now
especially since Society was memory
wiped from knowing who Peter Parker is
they still know who Spider-Man is they
just don't know who Peter Parker is
which is why the cafe owner says thank
you Spiderman yes this actor is Reuben
rabassa from Tim Robinson's I think you
should leave uh any other ideas stinky
what the movie screenwriter Jeff
loveness tweeted the age of men is over
the time of ant has come and yes Ant-Man
takes place in the I think you should
lead verse robassa also played a balloon
vendor Mr cardazzo in Agents of Shield
in the episode where lady Sif loses her
memory this shop is called Bridge donuts
and it has San Francisco themed Donuts
the Embarcadero Summer of Love the hate
Presidio Pier 39 Golden Gate and the
Candlestick that's ballpark where the
Giants play and tell all my friends who
asked me what's it like living in San
Fran little Insider tipria no one calls
it San Fran Here we call it San
Francisco or we call it SF it's one of
the many snobby things we do you know
like paying 3.50 for a donut let's move
on
turn it off now
we see Hank pym's house which is an
actual house located not far from where
I live on Buena Vista Avenue and Java
Street it's blue in real life but they
painted it red for production because
that's the color of ant-man's suit and
the WASP ended with this house being
transported to a Quantum Realm beach but
here I guess it's been moved back
Scott's daughter is Cassie Lang now
played by Catherine Newton and she shows
Scott and hope and Hank and Janet a new
piece of technology saying people still
need help Dad that's why we made this
who is we in the versions of this
trailer shown at Comic Con and d23
Cassie is showing this device to the
four adults for the first time something
she began working on during the blip to
try to rescue Scott while he was still
stuck in the quantum realm Cassie's
engineering partner could be Riri
Williams or maybe Peter Parker maybe
avastar ghost from the second film
returning in the MCU in Thunderbolts or
someone else in the Young Avengers with
Cassie Lang like time displaced Kang
variant iron lad young Nathaniel
Richards now this device is bronze and
silver colored looking like a vintage
stereo on the table around it is a pair
of headphones a world's best dad mug
shouldn't Thanos get that just also a
few books about ants Dr Eleanor's common
ants of California and journey to the
ants by birdhold dobler and Edward O
Wilson Paige Turners these are now this
device's cap amidst this tiny orb of
light the color blue make me wonder if
it could have been iron lad Nathaniel
who helped her build this without either
of these kids realizing that Kang knew
that his young variants 31st Century
technological know-how would lead the
Ant-Man family down into its Quantum
realm trap yes really this blue orb is
the key to it all I'm thinking it is
another kind of quantum realm energy
source in fact I think it's the same
kind of glowing orb that Kang loads into
his chamber like a battery and also
seems to be powering all the ships of
his air fleet this orb blasts all them
back and then sucks everything inward
the table the device is on spins and
gets sucked in but the device itself
remains floating I think the fact that
this table and everything in it got
sucked down in the quantum realm could
end up being important like they might
end up using that mug or those books for
something down there the whole family
gets sucked in and notice they get
sucked in in two distinct groups we had
hope Hank and Janet and one group then
separately Scott and Cassie so these
will be our two camps that we cut back
and forth between they all shrink down
into this orb and I like how their
bodies make the pimtek shrinking lines
that have always been these movies way
of showing the shrinking so it looks
like the size change progression in the
comics I love it let's move on where
are we okay the music in the trailer
transposes Goodbye Yellow Brick Road in
a few different ways throughout it and
all these different techno synthy sounds
but here over the studio logo it sounds
like it's a church organ
[Music]
Scott and Cassie look out over this
fractured landscape with floating rock
formations Columns of lava or some other
orange energy flow downward it's almost
like the quantum realm could be feeding
on energy from the surface realm in the
2017 Adventures Unleashed Kang War run
of the comics that gave us our perhaps
best take on Kang we learned that Kang
Prime sits at the End of Time living on
resources his variant is set up for him
across the time Stream So maybe this
orange energy that's flowing downward is
time or temporal energy that Kang in the
quantum realm is leaching from the
surface realm now I'm using the word
realm a lot here Marvel Studios has been
pretty loose in the way they've
described universes realities Dimensions
timelines Realms and planes sometimes it
seems like all these terms are just used
interchangeably but I think more and
more in baseboard titles the studio has
started to suggest that there are really
two broad categories of things we got
what we're going to call universes which
are really the numbered alternate Earths
of the Multiverse with variant versions
of each of us and our architecture kind
of looking similar but tweaked in
different ways so you got Universe 616
Universe 838 the University
Peter Parker the University of Andrew
Garfield Peter Parker all the different
universes we saw and what if but then in
the other category you got what we're
going to call Realms these are the more
surrealist Dreamscapes that look less
like our world and have this implied
ethereal spiritual connection The
ancestral plane the Duets Valhalla the
dark dimension hell the Nord mention the
shadow realm and yes I think the quantum
realm now maybe the TVA but we still
don't really know where the TVA is could
be somewhere in the quantum realm also
also I know when this trailer Janet
calls this all a secret Universe beneath
ours but I think that's just to help
broader audiences understand that it's
not another planet I think the Realms
that I mentioned share a border with all
universes Realms are buffer zones that
all universes can slip in and out of
kind of like an ocean between Universe
Islands so basically Universe 616 and
universe 838 both have waypoints in and
out of the same Quantum realm now look
at that purple sky above Scott and
Cassie the Cyclone portals there I think
these are time vortexes I think the ones
used by The Avengers to tap into the
quantum realm and in game to conduct the
Time Heist and the ones warned about by
Janet and don't get sucked into a Time
Vortex we won't be able to save you yeah
she called it a Time Vortex like a
cyclone and I think that's what these
look like basically I think the quantum
realm is porous with portals through
time and waypoints accessed via
subatomic shrinking that have made it
kind of a base lint tray collecting
misfits from throughout history and from
throughout Multiverse we made a few of
these Misfits in the next part a band of
Warriors confront Scott and Cassie they
are led by this Android with a glowing
cylindrical headpiece the armor looks a
bit Celestial to me but the head piece
reminds me of Miss minutes and other
orange colored TVA Tech like this thing
or at least this part of it could be a
cane creation that turned against him
the Android's group has four or five
subtypes in it we see some similarly
dressed dark hooded figures with
Firearms we see some women with staffs
we see some red robed figures with
glowing eyes then we get these little
dudes with glowing colored Fishbowl
heads looks like we're going to be
meeting several parts of quantum realm
society and I think this group are the
outcasts who fight against Kang's
dominance in the city hope Hank and
Janet walk through this jungle like Zone
I thought that bright wavy shape in the
background was the sky Horizon but it's
actually a super bright undulating Vine
Lighting in this jungle like an LED
snake light again maybe this is a
pipeline of temporal energy flowing
throughout the quantum realm beating
into the city in front of Janet I like
there's a few jellyfish creatures
floating up off the branches now here
elton's singing I should have stayed on
the farm I should have listened to my
old man and we actually see a farm here
in the quantum realm lanterns floating
above a field of crops where some
slug-like creatures with stalks Grays
and then this female hooded figure sees
something Crash Landing in the quantum
realm of her head I think this hooded
figure is Janet in her early years in
the quantum realm and she's seen a
vessel Crash Landing a vessel that is
piloted by Kang I think we are seeing
his initial arrival in the quantum realm
here this could be the moment these two
meet janica has survived her early years
by subsistence farming and then when
[ __ ] goes down between her and Kang the
empire in cities that Kang builds could
wipe out all the Farms like this and
develop new industrial means of resource
production like drainings and portal
energy from the surface realm Janet
takes Hank and hope riding on the back
of this pink manta ray type creature
they're passing through an area with
these spheres some glowing from within
with blue light others broken and empty
maybe these are like eggs or pods later
they do pass what appear to be some
Harvesters with tubes feeding the
backpack tanks with blue liquid maybe
these guys are tasked with draining the
pods I don't know a lot of weird shit's
going on in the quantum realm hope asks
her mother what are you so afraid of and
Janet says there's something I never
told you and I think that's something is
that she knew Nathaniel Richards Kang
and she could have stopped him earlier
but instead she just trapped him down
the quantum Realm by taking something
from him and we see the hand of Kang
placing a glowing orb into this chamber
with crystals that ignite upon contact
this device later appears plugged into
his golden platform maybe it's a fuel
source that activates some of this
technology and we see the Glorious city
of the quantum realm possibly the
interior of the city that we saw in the
background of the quantum realm and
Ant-Man the WASP which may end up being
quinopolis Kang's City in the comics or
maybe this movie will just call this
place quantumania there is a large
Central conical pyramid with floating
rings that assemble into place these
rings do resemble at least the 10 Rings
especially the way they lie the blue on
the sides Ms Marvel suggested there was
a connection between the 10 Rings and
The Bangles Bengals that appear to be
based on either the cree Nega bands or
quasars Quantum Vans and Ms Marvel
surprised all of us by being a show
weirdly about time travel and
specifically giving us clarification on
the rules of time travel in the MCU how
time travel is actually predestined all
scripted by Kang and when I asked him on
volani if Kang might have planned for
Kamala Khan to go back in time to save
her own grandmother her answer was
pretty interesting do you think Kang or
he remains might have planned
specifically for Kamala to go back in
time yeah okay so the inscription on the
bangle used to be what is destined for
you will come for you we did change it
after that but I like to use that as a
way of you know justifying how Kamala
goes back in time and and why that was
meant to happen so maybe all this
technology Quantum technology Creed
technology the 10 Rings is connected I
don't know I'm willing to go that far
but I do think that the use of rings and
circles is a kind of cultural statement
about Kang's Empire like the first thing
we saw from the Ant-Man set was a
production chair that used a specific
quantumania alphabet that seemed also
based on circles and Loops like the
alien heptopods movie arrival the use of
circles in their visual language was
really an expression of the way they see
time not linearly but as a circle No
Beginning No End just looping back on
itself endlessly and I think that's how
Kang sees time as well part of a
predestined Loop this is essentially how
Loki depicted the sacred timeline a
tight coil of Loops history circling
back on itself an infinite Circle in
infinite Loops we see how Kang has
assembled a vast Army Legions soldiers
either with blue helmets or blue face
protection which might be what Kang is
actually wearing when he's blue faced
these soldiers could be the pythians
Kings foot soldiers in the comics we see
two types of aircraft smaller ships with
rings on the back housing and fuel orb
and then larger ships with a fuel orb
contained behind the cockpit there's
also a turret on the right with
surface-to-air missiles and behind all
this notice the cityscape and the
distant background curves upward this
also seems to be the case in the
background behind Scott Cassie and hope
later at the end of the trailer this
whole city might be contained on another
ring structure like the glavus ring
world that we saw in the book of Boba
Fett I mean who knows maybe this whole
city is on one of the 10 rings that
would be ridiculous please don't quote
me on that let's move on now there's a
quick shot of Scott here in his setting
with color tones unlike anywhere else in
the trailer teal and magenta these
colors and the soft contrast reminds me
a lot of Mike Del Mundo's art in The
Avengers Unleashed Kang war comics that
I mentioned before from 2017. we know
the studio is interested in this run
because it was from this Comics
depiction of pharaoh Rama Tut that Moon
Knight episode 3 pulled its Kang Easter
egg for the Egyptian Thug's jacket I
didn't make that up folks a producer on
that show who's a friend of our Channel
confirmed that to us now I did summarize
this whole comic storyline in my video
how to kill Kang I highly recommend you
watch it because I really do think that
particular run in the comics is what's
going to inspire Kang in quantumania and
Kang in Avengers King Dynasty here we
see Kang standing on his golden platform
as Rings orbit him maybe peace is that
when they fully assemble make a perfect
sphere that completes Kang's time travel
vessel now one of the worships I pointed
out earlier flies toward another region
the quantum realm glowing red with
broken Rings smashed into each other
this might be where Scott is standing in
the shot I just mentioned maybe a first
attempt by Kang to build what would
become his Empire but in that footage
shown exclusively at Comic on a d23
there was a very brief shot of Modoc
with a robot face with red eyes that
burn this same color red we don't see
Modoc anywhere in this trailer and I
think it's because Marvel doesn't want
to give the internet a high quality
image to pause on and scrutinize to see
that kind of looks like
um there's a spoiler warning here
because this isn't confirmed and if you
don't want to know it skip to this time
I think we're gonna see that Modoc kind
of looks like Corey stole who is rumored
to return its Darren cross mutated into
a form of Modoc another shot shows Janet
turning a Dusty circular stone wall this
might be where she hid the thing that
she stole from Kang Janet Hope and Hank
walk into a bar with a four-armed
organic mechanized hybrid creature other
patrons include this dude who looks like
he is in the process of unraveling
actually more thoughts on this guy in a
bit and we see Bill Murray's character
Murray has described his character as a
bad guy and the d23 footage he greeted
Janet as if they once knew each other I
really love the theory that he could be
an elder of the universe but I don't
know Elders are really beings of the
cosmos of outer space not of different
Realms or Dimensions he's reportedly
playing a character named krylar who is
an obscure microverse resident in the
Hulk Comics I don't know if that's
confirmed ultimately I just think that
Murray's been playing an Elite member of
quantumania society a kind of puppet
political figure who leads the
equivalents of Kang's Vichy government
another shot shows Giants got surrounded
by warships after causing some
structural damage to the city we see him
and hope and her yellow wasps dude
staring them down in this movie they
clearly made Hope's suit a bit more
yellow to make her distinct among the
trio of herself alongside Scott who's
mostly red and casts to use mostly
purple see Janet in this glowing blue
Cavern is this arachnid demogorgon thing
pounces on her and then hope and Scott
and Janet and Hank are surrounded by
these cracks in reality like pink
lightning distorting the space around
this guy looks like he just got his ass
kicked he's more beaten up here than
anywhere else in the trailer so whatever
they just destroyed might have some kind
of load-bearing effect on this city or
this realm when you're King telling
Scott I can get you home and give you
more time if you help me so this is
Kang's deal that is offering him to
restore Scott's life before infinity war
and end game so that Scott can get those
five years with Cassie back Scott runs
around in a huge red Dome filled with
hundreds of other Ant-Man if you look
closely there's a giant Scott beside him
unraveling in a ribbon and the Scott
closest to us if you look closely for a
few frames actually splits into two what
is going on here I think Kang has
trapped Scott in this kind of chamber
with other variants from across the
Multiverse or just projections of them
the giant Scott I believe is in the
process of being pruned of being erased
and this is what TVA pruning looks like
in the quantum realm you unravel out of
existence similar to what Wanda did to
read Richards and what Thanos with the
reality Stone nearly did a mantis that
monster that Wanda sent after America
and Defender Strange In The Gap Junction
maybe that was a nearly unraveled
creature that just resisted its pruning
and that due to the bar maybe someone
can was torturing and started to unravel
but then thought never mind like the
sacred timeline we are all tightly
coiled bundles of temporal energy made
up of the infinite past inflection
points throughout history so to erase
any one of us from history the master
Weaver controlling everything must
untangle the knot of us and it's a
freaking mess kinda like when Sylvie
stabs he remains the coil of the Sacred
timeline unraveled into a mess as well I
think Scott like bug-themed Avengers
Spider-Man is gonna discover a shared
sense among his variants for Spider-Man
that shared sense his arachna frequency
AKA Spider Sense and the web of life and
Destiny that connects all of it I think
for Ant-Man it's gonna be his
multiversal ant colony and the way he
can sync with his ants is how he'll be
able to sync with his variants Scott and
Cassie flee and Kang floats down toward
us on this blue disc looking a lot like
Magneto and X2 his face is blue here as
it is in the comics actually looks
exactly like he does in comics crazy on
Marvel Studios he's pulling it off but I
think the blue is just going to be his
facial shielding emitting from his
helmet which is a pretty smart practical
way to maintain Kang's blue look while
not forcing John The Matrix to go around
blue in every scene and the triple shot
of the ant family the fact that Cassie
already has this purple suit on her
suggests that she might have already
been operating as a resizing superhero
before the events of the movie and the
Comic-Con put it Scott had to Baylor out
of jail so she's been doing some of
injury onto the final clip so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man okay as Kang strolls toward us
you can actually see his reflection in
that polished floor his face is blue
here so at the start of the scene his
mask is up but he lowers it as he talks
to Scott Kang has some unique scarring
on his face on either side of his cheeks
and his forehead remember he remains
face was unscarred so this presents a
unique backstory for the Conqueror
variant hanging the comics just has
these lines on his face but now they are
presented as Scar Tissue so he may have
got them while he was slaughtering
Avengers these d23 footage I saw goes
further Scott says you made a big
mistake I'm an Avenger Kang responds
you're an Avenger have I killed you
before Scott nervously asks what and
Kang says they all blend together after
a while who are you and Kang says just a
man who has lost a lot of time like you
but we can help each other with that
someone stole something from me and
you're the only one who can steal it
back so do we have a deal and Cassie
behind King shakes her head says no
don't take the deal and Kang uses
telekinesis to slam Scott against the
wall telling Scott that he is out of his
league so what was stolen from Kang well
my favorite theory is that it is not a
what it's a who and stolen from Kang was
his love in the comics ravona rensslayer
rensslayer could have been taken from
him by his rival he remains when he
remains used Elias to defeat all the
other gangs in that past multiversal war
and set up the TVA but I'm not so sure
about that theory now because Janet's
history with Kang just makes me wonder
if it could be a piece of technology for
his vessel that would allow Kang to
escape the quantum realm but maybe that
technology is a what and a Who
Miss minutes could she be Kang's AI
Navigator whatever was stolen from Kang
I think the truth either way is that
Janet's dark secret is that she trapped
a Time Lord in a realm with gaping time
vortexes given that time lord some if
not full ability to affect and benefit
from time travel she in effect created
the worst Kang folks there is a trend I
have found with theorizing for Marvel
films the more CGI the setting the more
bonkers the theories can get so between
now and February things are going to get
nuts follow me on Tick Tock Instagram
and Twitter at a boss follow me Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you